this is my absolutely favorite story
from the weekend remember the
Whistleblower who was going to blow the
lid off about the Biden crime family's
fraud and all these things that Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden have done James
Comer was talking about it we saw clips
of Chuck Grassley saying this is a this
is explosive we're going to bring in The
Whistleblower it's all going to happen
The Whistleblower is now missing
The Whistleblower is now missing and I
know what you're saying they probably
just don't want anything to do with this
right they are using ominous language to
say we we've got to figure that out the
Whistleblower has gone missing
that's really really weird Newsweek has
a report Republican admits key quote
informant against Joe Biden now missing
now Eve the term whistleblower was a
stretch to begin with because
whistleblower suggests they're blowing
the whistle about some kind of crime so
far we've not seen any evidence of that
neither of Republicans who say oh the
evidence is coming we're going to get
the evidence now the term that's being
used is an informant but even that is
being put within quotes because it's not
even really clear that they are that
representative James Comer a Kentucky
Republican admitted Sunday that
Republicans quote lost track of a key
witness in an investigation about the
Biden family's involvement in an alleged
bribery scheme this is just amazing
um there what we what we have is a memo
which includes redacted images of
transactions involving bank accounts
purportedly belonging to members of the
crime of the Biden family which they
believe are evidence of crimes nothing's
actually been proven you have to
understand so we go to Maria bartiromo's
program on Fox News yesterday
and
Maria Bartiromo tries to do this big
dramatic wait a second are you telling
me and it's just all so transparently
pathetic take a look at this hold on a
second Congressman did you just say did
you just say on live television and did
you just say that the Whistleblower or
the informant is now missing
well we we're hopeful that we can find
the Informer now remember these
informants are are kind of in the the
Spy business
it's like did you just say Congressman
you know they came to me and they said
sir the Biden crime witness is missing
big strong guys Tears in their eyes I
said how could that be it was because of
Obama who has been treated has treated
me very very unfairly because the
cupboards were bare when I took over for
him I was getting calls day and night
saying sir how do you do it how are you
doing it and we're going to be redoing
Mount Rushmore very strongly because the
informant proves everything about the
Biden crime family oh we can't find them
okay well I'm sure that that's something
that the Biden crime family orchestrated
right it's the hunter Biden body count
or whatever it is the next thing is
going to be
the way that this conversation has gone
if you look at it from the beginning
is so pathetic that it's actually
shocking Maria Bartiromo is even playing
along like even for her is it's it's a
bit much because the way the
conversation has been was Comer and
Grassley and others came forward and
said we have a whistleblower
who has all sorts of incredible evidence
against Joe Biden that crimes were
committed oh okay have you seen the
evidence well no no no but I'm sure that
he has it and we're gonna bring him in
very soon oh okay when is he coming in
well actually he's gone missing now oh
that's that's really kind of strange and
Maria Bartiromo falls for the entire
thing here she is wrapping it up on Fox
news and it really seems as though she
will believe anything Republicans tell
her just stunning a stunning breaking
news story this morning that some of
these people now may be missing Mr
chairman we're certainly going to be
covering and Reporting your findings
thank you which findings the findings
that there is no more whistleblower
because the Whistleblower is missing or
the findings that you are going to get
only if and when you find The
Whistleblower if you get them to come in
if they have any evidence if any of the
evidence checks out and if any of the
evidence that checks out actually points
to any crime even a single crime which
they've been looking into for years and
still haven't found a shred of evidence
about they love to say you know the left
always goes after Trump for all of this
supposed stuff but now we've got
evidence and they don't want to talk
about it first of all I've covered the
story from the beginning secondly there
isn't actually any evidence claiming
that someone you can't find has evidence
right that is not the same as having
evidence and the entire thing reminds me
of when
Tucker remember Tucker Carlson he went
on TV when he still had a show on Fox
News and he said we got a copy of the
hard drive we got a copy of the laptop
from Hell the hunter Biden laptop from
hell we got the copy on a USB drive
and we sent it to ourselves across the
country and it got lost in the mail
really you didn't make like a cloud
backup you didn't keep a USB drive with
you you didn't think to duplicate it you
know it just it's been lost we we
finally got Hunter's hard drive but it
simply was lost in the mail it's getting
harder to believe that these are serious
people and of course James Comer hasn't
been a serious person for a very long
time so listen as I've said before
I don't care about Hunter Biden in terms
of protecting him or politically
motivated reasons to pretend he did
nothing wrong just find me evidence of
crimes and then I will say prosecute
Hunter Biden but more importantly find
me a link to Joe Biden before I'm going
to think that there's actually political
relevance they have nothing do not allow
yourself to be misled they have nothing
as of right now okay real quick two
weeks from today Monday Memorial Day
we are doing a one day membership
blowout special to officially start the
2024 campaign the debates are going to
start it's going to be insane okay so
Monday Memorial Day that's the uh 29th I
believe is that right I don't even know
what I don't even know what year it is
uh yes Monday May 29th one day
membership special biggest discount of
the year if you've been thinking of
supporting the work that we do I would
love forget for you to get on my
newsletter mailing list you go to
davidpackman.com you just type in your
email address very easy to do
and a Monday Memorial Day in the morning
you'll get an email and it'll be an
email crying that will tell you how to
take advantage of this great membership
discount I'll say more about it between
now and then
if you or one of your parents is
starting to lose your hearing you're not
alone about 48 million Americans have
hearing loss and only one in five people
who would benefit from using a hearing
aid are actually using one our sponsors
MD hearing create FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aids that cost a
fraction of what you typically pay for
example MD hearings new Neo model costs
less than 10 percent of what those
marked up hearing aids are being sold
for at most hearing clinics and the Neo
is MD hearings smallest hearing aid ever
no one will even know that it's there I
have a close family friend who uses MD
hearing and loves it she said it
performs better than any hearing aid
that she's used and it's far less
noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free trial with a 100 money
back guarantee so you can buy with
confidence and they have a special deal
for my audience when when you buy a pair
of hearing aids you'll get them for just
149.99 each plus they'll include a free
extra charging case go to mdhearing.com
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below